jedes Böhnchen gibt ein Tönchen was
gibt's für ein Türchen ja das will ich
irgendwann rausfinden
[Musik]
Sally Kamera läuft kommen
silvester steht vor der Tür herzlich
willkommen in Sallys Welt der
Jahreswechsel steht bevor das ganze Jahr
ist schon vorbei und wir freuen uns auf
ein schönes neues Jahr 2023 mit tollen
neuen Projekten und
trauernd im alten Jahr hinterher weil es
leider schon vorbei ist es ging einfach
viel zu schnell es gibt so viel passiert
dieses Jahr aber egal heute geht's darum
heute geht's darum dass ich euch noch
ein schönes Rezept geben möchte was ihr
zum Beispiel an Silvester zubereiten
könnt falls ihr mit euren Freunden mit
euren Liebsten mit der Familie feiert
und deswegen gibt's heute Mini Burger
Mini Burger sind genial es gibt aber
auch schon einige Rezepte auf meinem
Kanal wie zum Beispiel Raclette mal
anders da könnte so Pizza Raclette
machen es gibt schon verschiedenste
Fingerfood Rezepte kaltes Buffet warmes
Buffet schaut einfach gerne auf meinem
Kanal vorbei süßes herzhaftes da ist
wirklich alles mit dabei heute habe ich
mir gedacht wie gesagt Mini Burger und
dafür wird es erstmal das Burger Brot
hergestellt
ich hoffe ihr verzeiht wenn ich jetzt
den Hut abnehme weil so kann ich nicht
drehen mal schon bisschen seriös bleiben
hier hier sind die Zutaten dafür
verwende ich einen halben Würfel Hefe
100 ml Wasser jeweils 15 Gramm Zucker
und Zuckerrübensirup 500 Gramm Mehl
130 Gramm Buttermilch ein Ei 80 g weiche
Butter und dann habe ich hier zwei
Teelöffel Salz und ihr könnt gerne noch
etwas Anis und Fenchel dazu nehmen dann
werden das so schöne gewürzbrötchen aber
ihr könnt sie auch standardisiert lassen
also ohne die Gewürze und falls ihr
keinen Zuckerrübensirup habt ist auch
nicht schlimm er gibt dem ganzen einfach
eine schöne Farbe und so einen leichten
schönen Geschmack geb dir zuerst die
Hefe mit Wasser und den beiden
Zuckerarten einfach in eine Rührschüssel
und dann gibt er auch schon mal die
Hälfte des Mehls dazu
und das Salz kommen zum Schluss mit dazu
und bei mir kommen jetzt noch wie gesagt
die Gewürze rein
[Musik]
jetzt verknete ich schon mal die Zutaten
und gebe nach und nach noch das
restliche Mehl mit rein die Butter und
das Salz und dann wird der Teig für etwa
10 Minuten schön geschmeidig geknetet
[Musik]
wow der Teig ist jetzt fertig ich nehme
ihn kurz raus vorm in schön zu einer
Kugel und lass ihn dann abgedeckt für
eine Stunde aufgehen oder auch gerne in
der Kenwood für etwa eine halb
Dreiviertelstunde bis er sich verdoppelt
hat oder wenn ihr habt auch gerne im
Backofen bei gerstufe geht in mein
Dampfbackofen ganz gut da dauert das
ganze nur 30 Minuten
und dann können wir in der Zwischenzeit
nämlich alles andere für die Burger
zubereiten
[Musik]
richtig perfekter Teig da klebt nämlich
einfach nicht
und immer schön abdecken
jetzt ist der Hefeteig gut aufgegangen
und ich mache jetzt Mini Burger ihr
könnt aber auch gerne normal große
Burger zubereiten aber ich finde gerade
für so einen Partyabend dann sind
mini-burger eigentlich immer ganz schön
vor allem sehr handlich und praktisch
ich nehme jetzt den Teig und portioniere
ihn deswegen in 24 Portionen ich habe so
ein Torten Einteiler der hat hier 12
oder 16 Portionen und ich mache das
jetzt hier erstmal so mit 12 und dann
kann ich die eben noch mal halbieren
[Musik]
und dann formt ihr die zu schönen
glatten Kugeln
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr diese Kugeln
entweder auf zwei Backbleche legen
abdecken und aufgehen lassen oder ihr
nehmt Muffinbleche das sind ganz normale
Muffinbleche das quasi die normale Größe
dann habe ich hier noch diese XXL
Muffinbleche aber vom Durchmesser her
sind sie gleich und ich nehme jetzt die
weil wenn die Bällchen dann etwas
aufgehen und wachsen dann haben sie
trotzdem so eine Umrandung und wachsen
eben nicht drüber hinaus
vielleicht muss jetzt nur kurz gefettet
werden mit backtrennspray dann legt ihr
die Kugeln rein deckt sie ab und lasst
sie noch mal etwa eine halbe Stunde bis
Stunde aufgeben
jetzt sind die Teiglinge gut aufgegangen
ich habe hier ein Eigelb habe es
bisschen mit Wasser verrührt gerade zum
Esslöffel Wasser der Ofen heizt jetzt
gerade vor auf 180 Grad Heißluft dann
kann ich nämlich beide Bleche
gleichzeitig backen und jetzt bestreiche
ich die hier schön und bestreue sie
damit Sesam und dann werden die Burger
Band gebacken ich hoffe sie werden
einfach wunderschön in seiner 5 habe ich
es nicht auch noch nicht gemacht
einfach schön drauf achten dass er eine
gute Beschichtung hat und gut fetten
trotzdem
und nach dem Backen bestreicht die Sie
am besten gleich ganz heiß noch mit
Butter dann werden sie noch mal saftiger
und dann lassen wir sie abkühlen aber
dazwischen werde ich dann schon mal die
Burger Füllung zubereiten auf jeden Fall
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier ein paar Zutaten ich
werde jetzt nämlich klassische Burger
machen mit fleischpetti aber auch
vegetarische oder sogar wir sind sogar
vegan tatsächlich das heißt ihr könnt
auch vegane Burger Bands machen und
vegane Patties machen und dann habt ihr
auch einen veganen oder eben
vegetarischen Burger ich starte jetzt
hier mal mit der bohnenmasse das hört
sich jetzt vielleicht komisch an aber
schmeckt richtig lecker dafür nehme ich
eine Dose Kidneybohnen das sind etwa 250
Gramm eine rote Zwiebel eine
Knoblauchzehe 70g Haferflocken 20 g Mehl
und zum Würzen nehme ich gemüsebrühpaste
Kreuzkümmel Senf Sojasoße Salz und
Pfeffer sollte jetzt erstmal zwiebel und
Knoblauchzehe schälen und einfach fein
hacken
das wird von der Farbe her wird es auch
richtig schön weil es einfach schön
dunkelrot und ja eigentlich auch schon
Richtung Fleisch geht muss ich sagen
wir verraten einfach nicht
dann kommen die Zutaten in eine
Rührschüssel ihr könnt das ganze auch
mit einem Mixer zubereiten oder eben
jetzt so einfach mit dem Messer
zerhacken
gibt dann die Bohnen dazu
und die restlichen Zutaten
[Musik]
die sind so schön
jetzt werden die Patties geformt wie
gesagt einmal habe ich hier diese nicht
Fleischmasse also die vegetarische
Variante und hier habe ich jetzt noch
ein bisschen Rinderhackfleisch einfach
ein bisschen durchgerührt da ist nichts
dran kein Gewürz und gar nichts denn das
wird einfach so dann gegrillt und später
mit der Soße und nach dem Grillen eben
gewürzt ich mache jetzt ja Mini Burger
deswegen habe ich auch eine Mini Burger
Presse braucht ihr nicht aber es
erleichtert euch die Arbeit das heißt
ich werde diese hier jetzt einmal
und dann immer so 60 Gramm Stücke
Formen reindrücken und dann auf
Backbleche setzen
und bei den Bohnen merkt man direkt so
diese mehlige Konsistenz
dann kommt es hier rein
ich hoffe es löst sich auch gleich
werden wir jetzt sehen
[Musik]
war perfekt portioniert sind genau 24 es
sind jetzt leider nur sieben
vegetarische geworden aber ich glaube
ich lege euch das Rezept so an dass ihr
12 vegetarische und 12 fleischige gehabt
die kommen jetzt ins Gefrierfach am
besten wenn ihr nicht so viel Platz habt
dann gerne in den Kühlschrank abdecken
Gefrierfach ist besser weil man später
die gefrorenen Patties einfach besser
grillen kann und in der Zeit bereite ich
jetzt noch bisschen die Soße vor und die
Füllung des Burgers und dann bin ich
schon soweit zum zusammensetzen
für die burgersoße verwende ich als
Grundzutat Mayonnaise das sind jetzt
etwa 150 Gramm saure Gurken eine kleine
Zwiebel oder eine Schalotte etwas Senf
ich habe ich Salz und Pfeffer Curry und
Paprikapulver das ist edelsüß etwas
Ketchup und Weißweinessig die Zwiebel
habe ich jetzt bereits geschält die
könnt ihr gemeinsam mit den sauren
Gurken einfach ganz schön fein hacken
oder eher tut alles in den Mixer und
dann können das auch im Mixer zubereiten
so bleibt ein bisschen stückiger
Biss und ansonsten wird es eine
geschmeidige Soße und die könnt ihr auch
gerne in größere Menge zubereiten denn
die ist im Kühlschrank so ungefähr eine
Woche haltbar oder sogar länger
tatsächlich und dann habt ihr immer so
ein bisschen sowas hervorrat und das ist
eine eigentlich eine Pommes Soße eine
holländische die man gerne eben beim
Pommes essen verwendet ich finde ihr
dass die Holländer wirklich die
Holländer haben so die besten Pommes und
immer schön mit verschiedenen Soßen
deswegen kann man sich da schon mal
schöne Rezepte abgucken
[Musik]
und dann noch die Kochen schon
und dann wird eigentlich alles andere
hier verrührt
[Musik]
das heißt ich habe jetzt meine Burger
Brötchen die Patties die Soße und was
ihr jetzt auf den Burger gibt bleibt
jetzt euch überlassen ich bereite jetzt
hier alles vor ich werde rote Zwiebeln
schneiden ich werde Jalapeños noch dazu
holen werde die Burger brötchen
aufschneiden und eine Grillplatte
aufsetzen jetzt werden Burger gegrillt
hier seht ihr jetzt alle Zutaten also
die Patties die Burger Brötchen dann
habe ich etwas Käse Paprika kleine
Chilischoten unsere burgersoße ein paar
Cornichons bzw einfach Gurken für Burger
die sind schon geschnitten getrocknete
Tomaten rote Zwiebeln und ich glaube ich
so wie einfach dazu noch ein paar
maiskörbchen jetzt kommt hier etwas
Olivenöl in meinen Bräter normalerweise
mag ich es auch sehr gerne Burger
draußen auf dem Grill so zubereiten aber
heute ist mir einfach zu kalt und ich
bin schon so angeschlagen deswegen
bleiben wir heute hier ich habe jetzt
hier Olivenöl schon rein
das ganze wird erwärmt und da jetzt bei
uns keiner ein Problem damit hat Weg wie
oder nicht weg wie werde ich jetzt beide
Sorten in einer Pfanne braten aber wenn
ihr das Trennen wollt dann trennt
natürlich auf jeden Fall ich kann auch
schon mal die Brötchen nicht fein
schneiden sondern Ebene zur Hälfte
durchschneiden
und was ich hier auch schön finde falls
ihr das wirklich zu Silvester zubereiten
wollt dann lasst doch einfach jeden
seinen Burger selber belegen
kann man auch machen oder eben schon
fertig anrichten als Platte warmhalten
und dann ist es auch perfekt
und jetzt hier in der Pfanne einfach von
beiden Seiten anbraten wichtig ist
erstmal die eine Seite etwa drei bis
vier Minuten bei Mittel hoher Hitze und
dann erst umdrehen wenn sich so eine
Kruste gebildet hat dann klebt nämlich
auch nichts an
[Musik]
die sind jetzt gleich durch die Brote
lege ich jetzt einfach auch noch dazu
können Sie so ein bisschen
karamellisieren und natürlich wieder
warm werden denn wir sind nicht mehr da
und wer will kann jetzt hier gleich noch
ein bisschen Cheddar drauflegen dann
schmilzt er schon
[Musik]
wenn ihr viele Burger zubereitet dann
ist es empfehlenswert dass ihr die
Patties am bratet und dann den Käse
drauf und ab in den Ofen unter die
Grillfunktion dann schmilzt der Käse
nämlich schön und alles bleibt schön
warm denn in einer Platte kriegt man
jetzt auch nicht alle 24 Portionen
fertig aber muss es jetzt bei uns gar
nicht denn ich werde die Patties
eingefroren lassen die Brötchen kann ich
auch einfrieren oder und dann können wir
sie immer nach Bedarf einfach rausholen
jetzt stelle ich erstmal einen Burger
fertig bzw zwei einen Veggie
und einen normalen
einen fleischsperger
mal das ich weiß ganz genau dann Zacken
sagen viele wieder aha das ist der
normale und der andere ständig normale
Leute
der klassische und der Welt steht doch
so etwas Soße dann machen wir hier
[Musik]
Portion mit Fleisch
hier vegetarisch
Gürkchen bisschen Paprika
[Musik]
getrocknete Tomaten
Zwiebelringe
habe ich alles
ja Jalapeno lasse ich jetzt erstmal weg
und dann kommt der Deckel drauf und
Samira darf jetzt heute mal probieren
okay Sami bist du bereit für den Burger
ja und bereit für das letzte rezeptvideo
in diesem Jahr ja
in diesem Jahr ist sind diese Burger
also ich habe hier einmal den
fleischburger den Veggie Burger welche
möchtest du probieren ich würde beide
mal probieren perfekt ich habe die jetzt
blöderweise auseinander
geschnittenführung der Stadt Waghäusel
für die Senioren ne
richtig süß hat ihre Ballettgruppe habe
da einen schönen Seniorennachmittag
verbracht haben sie sich gefreut ja sehr
schön
ich habe nur vergessen tatsächlich
drüber zu gehen aber die Soße Holz raus
also das ist daran denken beim Anbraten
danach mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen oder
schmeckt gut die Wäsche Variante bin ich
richtig gespannt
und dann schneide ich einmal durch
wir haben auch gerade so dieses große
Unglück dass
du weißt eigentlich auch noch nicht
dass unser Daves Burger Grill hier
schließt
[Musik]
und die andere hätte gehen hier weg die
gehen in Odenwald die öffnen dort ein
Restaurant deswegen haben wir bald kein
Daves Burger mehr hier ich bin traurig
ja wir gehen sie besuchen okay wir gehen
Dave besuchen und sobald ich weiß wo er
da im Odenwald ist da machen wir auch
Werbung für ihn unser Dave das ist so
wieso ein richtiges original der der kam
hierher und machte mit seinem food Truck
richtig geile Burger dann hat er hier
die Hundehütte da hinten angemietet bei
Hundeverein macht dort die genialsten
Burger und jetzt zieht da oben wir sind
richtig traurig zum Jahreswechsel also
eigentlich jetzt
naja probieren wir noch hier die
vegetarische Variante der ist richtig
gut
das sind Bohnen
jedes Böhnchen gibt einen Tönchen was
gibt's für ein Tönchen ja
also ich wünsche euch einen
wunderschönen Jahreswechsel viel Spaß
beim Zubereiten
falls ihr die Burger nicht zubereiten
wollt wie gesagt wir haben ganz viele
andere silvesterrezepte bereits auf dem
Kanal schreibt mir gerne wie ihr jetzt
den Jahreswechsel verbringt feiert ist
Silvester feiert ihn nicht macht ihr das
in der großen Runde oder doch in der
kleinen gemütlichen Runde Party oder
doch ein bisschen Raclette und Rummy
abspielen wir müssen Überraschung euch
verraten
wir werden auf jeden Fall ein schönes
Silvesterfest feiern
in kleiner aber man kann gar nicht so
richtig sagen egal lass dich überraschen
also euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
schönen Jahreswechsel ein wunderschöne
Party wünsche ich euch wir sehen uns
wieder im nächsten Jahr und das nächste
Video was kommt ist ein Jahresrückblick
mit den schönsten emotionalsten
traurigsten und lustigsten Momenten des
Jahres 2022
[Applaus]
[Musik]